you have
made some very strong claims you have
argued
that in fact the vaccine campaign that
we are currently engaged in is so
dangerous
that it should be halted and i will say
i don't know if you're right i cannot i
cannot determine
based on what i understand if you're
right but what i can say
is that you are making sense right this
is
frightening in and of itself that your
argument is
completely coherent whether or not it is
true
this is at least a question that should
be engaged by those who are making
policy around this because
the possibility of making our viral
situation with respect to covid
worse is present and
you know we we are creating the hazard
of the future that we will be
confronting a year or two down the road
by our actions now and so
um were we to have reacted differently
at the beginning of kovid we might not
be in the situation we're in now
were we to act differently now we will
be in a different situation
years down the road and so we are always
sort of setting the stage of our next
battle and it is in that context that we
have to engage your argument and take it
quite seriously so what in a nutshell
is your argument for the hazard that we
may be creating
so my argument is first of all
as i was always saying these vaccines
are
would be perfect to be used
outside of a pandemic why i'm saying
this
because if you use them if you use
vaccines before you get exposed
to the virus well in this case it's a
virus
you can build a full-fledged immunity as
you were pointing out bread this takes
time
most of the current vaccines even
require two doses
you have been pointing out about this
this clonal expansion
in the meantime you acquire memory
you acquire higher affinity etc this is
a process before you acquire the
full-fledged
immunity so if you have this
full-fledged immunity
and then you get exposed to the pathogen
you literally have
everything you need to fight off this
pathogen
right and and there is absolutely no
problem and that's what i'm
always what i have always been saying
i'm not talking about
maybe secondary uh effects or
adverse events etc this is not my
field of specialty other people can
discuss this so i'm not talking about
really the quality of the vaccines or
adverse events but in principle
this is a correct vaccine to be used
outside of a pandemic so let me just
pause you there
let's say just hypothetically speaking
let's say that the virus had uh
emerged in wuhan and
the world had limited its spread let's
say that it was
kept to eurasia
and the rest of the world had not faced
the
virus then if we took one of these
mrna vaccines for example and vaccinated
the population so that
80 90 percent of the population was
vaccinated before
encountering the virus before the virus
crossed any ocean for example
then we would expect this to work very
well
sure and the hazard of it would be low
uh even if it was true that it only
produced
let's say 80 percent
uh immunity and even if it was true
that people shed some people who
were vaccinated but then became infected
did shed some virus and occasionally
infected other people
is that fair to say that this will still
be a reasonable
a reasonable campaign yeah the only
thing i would like to add but just to be
clear
for the audience is that here we are
talking about the original virus about
the wild virus the original gohan virus
right we are not yet talking about
variants
right under that assumption what you're
saying is
perfectly correct and fine because
even if you don't
prevent infection completely and you
diminish
only the viral load as long as the virus
will have not will not have enough
opportunity because the infectious
pressure is so low
to propagate it will it will die out
so that is perfectly fine and and so you
can control it
so this is the thing that i think is
too subtle for most people to to get
and hopefully we can help them see the
difference
the vaccine from the point of view of
the patient the patient goes
they get they you know go through
whatever anxiety they have about needles
and
unknown hazards of vaccines and they get
their shot that looks the same
to people whether they're being
vaccinated in the midst of a pandemic
or in advance of a pandemic but from the
point of view of the evolutionary
landscape
these two things are completely
unrelated right
introducing the vaccine when the the
virus has already gotten a foothold and
has started to diversify
getting a vaccine is actually you know
it's like
showing up imagine that your nation was
being invaded
right and there's a question about how
useful
your rifle is when
the ship you know some little boat with
12 people on it shows up on the shore
your rifle might be very useful
right if you show up with that same
rifle against an army of
10 000 you're gonna get shot and
you know you may actually be in a worse
position because you'll give away you
know
you're shaking your finger especially if
this happens
before you can completely charge your
rifle
your arm is not fully charged and you
are already under attack
right already under attack so this is i
mean in some sense this is
uh this is very straightforward to me
because i'm used to thinking in
evolutionary terms
right and so the idea of
to me the virus looks very different
even though the particles may be very
similar to each other
the virus looks very different when it
has
a huge number of individuals in which to
engage in evolutionary experimentation
versus a tiny number of individuals
where the chances of it happening on
anything useful are very small
right once you've got the huge canvas
the chances that the virus is going to
learn new tricks are
a hundred percent and in fact it's doing
it and you know as i said at the top
no surprise at all that us having
botched the initial reaction to the
virus which frankly
in my opinion should have been much
stronger right we should have had a much
more
intensive campaign to to control the
spread of the virus
early on and we might not be dealing
with this you know
half-assed long-term uh
you know set of measures that are
increasingly draconian and having all
sorts of other effects a short
intense uh control effort would have
been more effective
in part the reason that i say that is
because
it's just much easier to address you
know if this was an invasive species
and there are 10 individuals right
finding them is very uh effective you
could find them you can eliminate them
you're done once the thing has covered
the landscape
it's a whole different puzzle even if
the uh the individual
uh critters aren't aren't very different
so all right we've got a difference
between
these vaccines and their utility in
advance of a pandemic versus in the
pandemic
we are in the pandemic and now what do
you see the hazard being
of a mass vaccine campaign
well um so these vaccines will
definitely
induce an immune response that's what we
have been explaining
so what we know is that
it takes time to develop an immune
response
so during that time your immune response
is not optimal
right it's not fully mature that is one
thing
the other thing is we are already
dealing
before we started the mass vaccination
campaign
before they got rolled out properly we
had already variants
so again the immune response
that you are mounting when you have been
vaccinated
is suboptimal towards a variant
that has a spike protein which is
different from the spike protein in the
vaccine
so the vaccinal antibodies against the
spike protein are
suboptimal because the s protein
of the variant is not the same so we are
when we when we are vaccinating people
as i was saying
you're you are going to war but your arm
isn't charged yet you are already
fully under attack and you still need to
mount this antibody response
and you are attacked by things that you
have not learned to properly recognize
so the immune response is suboptimal so
now
so this creates what we call an immune
pressure
a pressure it's suppressed it's
definitely a pressure on the virus the
the the virus isn't happy with with with
his immune response
but it is going to be able to adapt
to that immune pressure why am i saying
this i'm saying this because
when you have whenever you have to
adapt a virus or a microorganism but i'm
talking about
viruses to unfavorable conditions let's
let's let's say you you would like to do
this in the lab
you have a virus and you would like it
to adapt the virus to an unfavorable
condition
that unfavorable condition could be
cultivating for example
an influenza virus on eggs instead of on
a cell culture
or incubating your virus on a
temperature that is not
ideal for the cells to grow and for the
virus to produce
but it could also be the unfavorable
condition could also be
an immune pressure antibodies for
example that are present
so if you would like to do this in the
lab you would like
to adapt a virus to unfavorable
conditions
what you would do is you would take that
virus and you would put it on a cell
line
in the presence of those unfavorable
conditions so in this
in this case it would be a suboptimal
antibody dose let's say
but then that is not sufficient because
of course you have always and that is
the argument of many people yeah you
have all the time variants and mutations
etc
of course but now you will select
certain mutations
that are capable of dealing with this
unfavorable condition
right so you will select those variants
but that is not sufficient
because it's not because you have done
this selection one single time
that this variant is now going to become
dominant in the population
it will still have a very low we call
this a viral title
a very low concentration but now
if you take that virus or you know the
all these viruses and you're now going
to inoculate this
on another cell culture under the very
same conditions of immune pressure
and then you do it again and again and
again
then ultimately this mutant
will adapt to these unfavorable
conditions and it will have a
competitive advantage
compared to the original viruses and
that is how
you know in the course of time this
population
of these mutants that originally were
only president very low concentration
will now become predominant so now you
trans uh you extrapolate these two to
people
what you're going to do in order to be
able to adapt
to adapt a viral mutant you would need
to passage a virus from one person to
the other
but in order for that virus to be able
to adapt it would
be important that these people are under
the same
immune pressure also experiencing a
situation
of suboptimal immune response and what
i'm saying is that
if you're already having variance before
you start your vaccination campaign
and then you're immunizing in the heat
of the pandemic
where while the immune response is built
up
you are already under attack many many
people of course in such situation are
going to be
to be experiencing a suboptimal immune
response
and hence this will enable mutants that
occasionally emerge of course to adapt
and to gain a competitive advantage and
to become dominant in that population
and then of course we have a problem
because this is what we call selective
selective immune escape you select it
and you enable the virus to adapt to
that situation so it becomes predominant
and that is what we are seeing right now
as soon as you have an infectious
variant popping up
guess what i mean it takes like a few
weeks or it becomes predominant in in
the population
[Music]